Uh, let's go next to our caller from the six
two, three area code. Who is calling today
from six to three.
Can you, uh, can you hear me, David?
You know, I can, who's this?
Oh my gosh, this is amazing. Hey David, this
is Matthew. I've been, uh, I've been watching
use and, uh, you're on the drunken peasant's
actually like forever ago.
Yeah. I don't even know. Remember when that
was.
Yeah, it's been a while. I actually was on
the trip, uh, going to Europe to be with my
dad for awhile and I had to call. I tried
calling over there, but now that I'm back
in the U S a U S number, I'm glad it actually
went through, but I'll stop talking about
all that kind of stuff. Uh, actually it's
not really a question, but it's more of like
getting your opinion if you think this is
even feasible or not because basically, well,
let me put it in this context first because
I have like two like fundamental sets of beliefs
I guess that I've incorporated into what I'm
about to try to explain a at most two are
basically good ideas that help people are
good ideas. Like regardless of their origin
or where they come from. Like if you can implement
them successfully and it's proven to have
results that you know, they obviously, you
know, they should be implemented at the other
one, excuse me, is that if corporations do
not exist for the people that by proxy or
not by proxy but a by default be directly
or like good existence against us because
they're not seeing us as like a, a, what's
it called, like a reliable or like a consumer
base that they work is like the best product
possible.
I mean, how many stories are we gonna see
where corporations have been cutting costs?
They've been trying to get,
I think I got, okay, so get given, given that
that's the context, Matthew, what, what were
you going to ask my opinion about?
Yeah, sorry, I just bet trying to waste time,
but basically a [inaudible] do you think that
it would be feasible after implementing a
policy? Uh, or maybe not a policy, but, uh,
some kind of regulation to where not only
the workers for these companies are getting
paid, like the minimum wage that's about to
where they could actually go out and buy goods
and services in this capitalistic society
that we're all a part of that will therefore
increased demand for certain products have
been supply. If they can do that with also
set backs from wages for themselves at the
highest levels of all the other excess, uh,
what's it called? Profits. All of the know
things at the end of the year. All that should
be put back into the business. Basically.
It to ensure quote things like quality control
and uh, you know, making sure that they have
the best product possible. Because like I
said before, if a company is existing for
the people to bear existing against us just
to exploit us basically.
So, so are you saying, so basically that's
just, it's mandating com companies B uh, nonprofits
or co-ops. I mean a nonprofit at the end of
the year, you know, the money gets, gets,
it stays in the organization and uh, that's
a very particular type of alignment, you know,
as far as maximum wages, I'm not sure how
the, the legal infrastructure that would be
V V would be complicated. It would be very
hard to actually implement and I think there
would be massive, massive opposition. I think
there's a lot of lower hanging fruit that
could be done first in terms of democratizing
the workplace, including, uh, putting workers
on boards of directors, having worker representation
on boards of directors. And there's a lot
of other things that would be much simpler
to do legislatively and legally that I would
look at first.
Yeah, of course. You know, I'm not really
a, I mean, I do spend quite a bit of time
thinking about these topics, but obviously
like this is your, you know, your job. But
like I said, I've been watching you since
you're on the drug and peasants. Awhile ago
I'd just been sitting on this for a while.
I thought, well, if I were to get anybody's
opinion, let me try to get David pack bins.
Matthew, I appreciate you of me so highly.
I, I'm flattered. I'm glad that you were able
to get on and I do hope to hear from you again.